so let's review the unit circle
definition of trig functions a little
bit right over here i've drawn a unit
circle and when we say unit circle we're
talking about a circle with radius one
so for example this point right over
here is the point
one comma zero x is equal to one y zero
this point is the point zero comma one
this is the point
negative one comma zero and this is the
point zero
comma negative one that the radius over
here the distance from the center of the
circle which is at the origin to any
point in the circle or any point on the
circle i should say this radius is equal
to one
so the unit circle definition of trig
functions leverages this unit circle
that's why it's called the unit circle
definition and we saw that if we define
an angle as
the kind of bottom side of the angle
being along the positive x-axis
and then the other side of that angle
thinking about where it intersects the
unit circle so let's say that this is
the angle theta
we define
sine of theta and cosine of theta or
cosine theta and sine of theta as the x
and y coordinates of this point at which
this this side of the angle this the
side that is not the positive x-axis
where that intersects the unit circle so
for example this point right over here
if we would call this the x-coordinate
of this point so this value right over
here
we would call that cosine of theta
we would call that cosine of theta and
the y coordinate of that point which is
this point right over here we would call
that
we would call that sine of theta in
previous videos on the unit circle we
talked about why this is really just a
natural extension
of the sohcahtoa definition what's
useful is it starts to work for negative
angles it works for angles it even works
for 90 degree angles it works for angles
more than 90 degrees it works for angles
less than 90 degrees so it's really
really really useful but what i want to
do is leverage what we already know
about the unit circle definition of trig
functions to to help prove the
pythagorean identity it almost falls out
of the fact that this point right over
here is on a circle a circle of radius
one
so what is the equation of a circle with
radius one centered at the origin
well the equation of that is x squared
x squared
we have other videos where we really
prove this using the distance formula
which is really just an application of
the pythagorean theorem the equation of
a circle of a unit circle centered at
the origin is x squared plus y squared
plus y squared is equal to
is equal to 1 is equal to the radius
squared this distance right over here is
equal to 1.
well we've already said that we're
defining cosine of theta as the
x-coordinate of this point and we're
defining sine of theta as the
y-coordinate of this point and this
point is sitting on the circle it has to
satisfy this relationship right over
here so that means well if we're
defining cosine of theta to be the x to
be this x value sine of theta to be the
y value and it has to satisfy this
relationship that means that cosine of
theta squared plus sine squared of theta
plus sine
squared of theta needs to be equal to
needs to be equal to one or sine squared
theta plus cosine squared of theta needs
to be equal to 1. and that's just from
the point this is the x cosine theta is
the x coordinate sine theta is the y
coordinate they have to satisfy this
relationship which defines a circle so
cosine squared theta plus sine squared
theta is 1. now this is called as we've
seen in other videos this is called the
pythagorean
pythagorean identity and you say why is
that useful well using this if you know
sine of theta you can figure out what
cosine of theta is going to be or vice
versa and if you know one of cosine of
theta and then you could say you know
cosine theta then you use this to figure
out sine of theta then you could figure
out tangent of theta because tangent of
theta is just sine over cosine but if
you're a little bit confused as to why
this is called the pythagorean identity
well it really just falls out of where
even the equation of a circle even came
from if we look at this point right over
here
if we look at this point right over here
which we're saying is the x coordinate
is cosine theta and the y coordinate is
sine of theta what is the distance
between that point and the origin
well to think about that we can
construct a right triangle
so this distance right over here
this distance right over here and so
that we can deal with any quadrant i'll
make it the absolute value of the cosine
theta is this distance right over here
and this distance right over here
is the absolute value of the sine of
theta the absolute value of the sine of
theta
and i obviously don't have to take the
absolute value for this first quadrant
here but if i went into the other
quadrants and i would have set up a
similar right triangle then the absolute
value is at play and so what do we know
from the pythagorean theorem this is a
right triangle here the hypotenuse has
length 1. so we know that this
expression squared the absolute value of
cosine of theta squared
plus this expression squared which is
this length
plus the absolute value of the sine of
theta squared needs to be equal to the
length of the hypotenuse squared which
is the same thing which is is going to
be equal to 1 squared or we could say we
this is the same thing
if you're going to square something the
sign if it's negative it's going to be
negative times a negative so it's just
going to be positive so this is going to
be the same thing as saying that the
cosine squared theta plus sine squared
theta
plus sine squared theta is equal
is equal to 1.
so once again or i guess this is why
it's called the pythagorean identity and
actually that's even where the equation
of a circle comes from it comes straight
out of the pythagorean theorem where
your hypotenuse is a one it has length
one